the role of CFO has changed dramatically
CFOs were supposed to be experts in
accounting and finance now in Dynamic
environments they are expected to be
experts in strategy as well
I needed a course that could help me to
become a better CFO the ability to
become more engaged in financial matters
with our company was an opportunity for
advancement we expose the participants
to experts at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business who have done
research in the area of leadership as
well as strategic thinking the
participants by engaging with these
experts as well as amongst themselves
will be able to learn these attributes
and in a way that helps accelerate their
path becoming the CFO I've moved from
the technical aspects of being a finance
professional to a strategic partner and
I was looking for a class that would
help me jump to the next level we want
the participants to gain a greater
understanding of current trends and
finance and Technology develop a
long-term vision and appreciate strategy
Frameworks assess and enhance their
personal leadership style to be change
agents that drive Innovation and lead to
cultural change in their organizations
they give you the best of the best of
what is happening in the world of
finance and strategy I'm going to take
back a different attitude a different
perspective it's not only the professors
the lectures the cases but also the
whole environment
the ecfo program has been a fantastic
opportunity for me
this program is supporting me in every
way not only me it will support my
organization
it has been a transformational
experience